so the Dead Space remake came out a
couple days ago and anyone that has
played it has likely noticed the various
things that were not present in the
original release While most of these
changes are gameplay related like usual
we're going to focus on the story
instead today I want to look at the Dead
Space original and remake and compare
the stories to see what these changes
are and if the Remake is better than the
original of course spoil the warning
ahead for Dead Space 1 the Remake and
the opening moments of Dead Space 2.
this is a new series I'm starting here
on the channel so let me know if you
enjoyed by liking the video and
commenting your thoughts about it down
below I would love to do more of this on
other remakes as well like the upcoming
Resident Evil 4 and Silent Hill 2
remakes
regardless let's not take up any more
time and let's get started so as you
would expect the story of the Remake is
not drastically different from the
original the course structure is still
the same but the finer details are
what's been changed Isaac and the crew
still arrive at the ishimura and Isaac
still learns about Nicole's fate and the
story of the marker but how he learns
about these details in the remake are
different as such I won't be going in
depth on the story of dead space as it's
unnecessary plus I've already covered
the entire Trilogy in a previous video
see if we want a story critique on the
Dead Space Trilogy feel free to watch
that one after this video
getting back on track the first thing
you'll notice is that Isaac actually
Speaks now this was admittedly something
that signaled some red flags for me
while I would have liked Isaac to speak
in the original his silence actually
helped the narrative Nicole's fate is
one of the biggest mysteries of the game
and having Isaac stay quiet during his
interactions with Nicole forces us the
player to think of the mystery ourselves
if he were to talk during these
conversations then the player would be
more inclined to agree with what Isaac
is thinking Isaac thinks she's alive so
all think so too this is exactly what
ends up happening in the remake Isaac
fully believes that she is alive which
makes sense but it does ruin some of the
mystery the bonus to having Isaac talk
though is that the characters can have
more interactions and thus more depth
Isaac in the original was just ordered
around and couldn't really object to
anything because he couldn't speak in
the remake he takes a more active role
during the infection Isaac is still
doing things like planting the SOS
Beacon and reactivating the comms array
but instead of someone telling him to do
it he actively suggests the idea
furthermore Isaac only speaks when he
needs to I'm on the record as saying
that if Isaac were to speak I'd want him
to be more like his Dead Space 2
rendition as it gives Isaac a chance to
have an actual personality without going
too overboard with the dialogue like how
most modern AAA games have done the
Remake is exactly what I wanted Isaac
only speaks when talking with the rest
of the crew but outside of that
especially during gameplay he's silent
and all that can be heard are his
aggressive screams and grunts but Isaac
isn't the only one with some changes as
the rest of the Kelly and crew also got
their fair share the two pilots Johnston
and Chen have more screen time in this
entry which wasn't exactly hard to pull
off since they died in the first 10
minutes still this shows how little
importance they are to the story at
large and the Remake decided that that
wasn't good enough Johnson ends up
actually staying on the ship this time
meaning she won't be killed during first
Contact this was a nice change even if
she does end up dying anyway once we
revisit the Kelly in an hour later
unlike Johnston though Chen is
constantly brought up throughout the
story his main purpose is to replace
some Necromorphs in specific scenes
three of which are the most important he
replaces the leaper that was seen in the
call between Isaac Hammond and Kendra
he's also the Necromorph that Hammond
locks in the Escape pod which also means
that he's the sole reason the USM Valor
was infected as that escape pod was
retrieved by the ship and he is also the
cause of Hammond's death instead of a
Necromorph Brute while it does feel a
bit like the devs were trying to force
the characters to be present more I
think given the unique take on the story
it actually fits as anyone who's played
Dead Space knows Dead Space 1's plot was
small in terms of World building as it
was just centered around the ishimura
for the most part as things progress
though mainly around chapter 10 the game
started transitioning to the overarching
plot conveying to the player that the
story was more than just the ship the
Remake handles this quite well but also
introduces these ideas much earlier in
the playthrough in chapter 4 around the
time Isaac is tasked with preparing the
ads cannons he comes across the
unitologist ritual as well as a
broadcast coming from the TV Isaac
around this time will then mention how
he hates unitology and that his mother
was a unitologist this was something
that was only ever mentioned in a text
log on New Game Plus back in the
original hell the convergence event one
of the most important steps in the
Necromorph process is brought up by Dr
Mercer the first time you meet him and
unless I'm mistaken this isn't even
mentioned until Dead Space 2 so the game
is really skipping ahead here while it
was originally put off by this I think
in context it fits quite well the Dead
Space remake is trying to develop the
story of the markers and units autology
a lot earlier is it will allow for a
smoother transition when going from the
Remake to Dead Space 2. circling back to
the crew of the kelian this is why
despite some of their interactions
feeling a bit forced as it still has to
stay within the bounds of the original I
actually enjoyed it having Hammond talk
about seeing Chen includes the player
run on the fact that the Necromorphs
were originally a part of the crew and
that they can be reanimated into these
things when they die to be fair the
reveal of the infector also does this
too but still having it be Chen was a
nice touch as it makes his interactions
with him and feel more personal because
instead of dying to a brute Hammond ends
up pushing a Necromorph Chen into the
singularity core this was intended to
show the player How deep the marker's
effects go as everyone seems to be
succumbing to its hallucinations in the
original it was only Isaac and Dr kind
who were experiencing these kinds of
effects there were a few moments when
Kendra saw her brother but then ever
stopped her from completing her main
objective and the same is true with the
Remake hiding Hammond into the mix
intensifies that Sinister feeling that
the markers have always conveyed the
Remake seemed to want to make all the
chapters have some sort of meaning in
regards to the overarching plot as in
the original things didn't really start
moving until chapter 10. the previous
nine chapters were more about escaping
and repairing the ishimura the original
did sprinkle in some details here and
there about the marker and the
Necromorphs but they were very few and
far between at this point it's really
hard to say which game did it better as
I think both games are trying to do
different things the marker and
unitology were introduced towards the
end of the original so a lot of those
details weren't mentioned yet but in the
remake it was talked about much earlier
so more time had to be spent on showing
the markers and the effects it has so
it's not really a discussion about
whether or not the Remake did a good job
of conveying the story of Dead Space
it's more about which method of
Storytelling you prefer that being said
while I was a fan of how both games
handled the story the changes made by
the Remake did ruin a couple of
characters for me mainly the ones not a
part of the kelian that being Dr Mercer
Nicole and Elizabeth cross Dr Mercer is
as Twisted as he's always been but it's
these two interactions with him that
were a bit off-putting first was the
stasis I don't recall stasis ever
trapping someone like this for an
extended period of time the issue though
is that stasis is only ever really used
as a gameplay mechanic and having
someone freeze for over two minutes
would break the gameplay so the game
does have to bend the rules a bit still
I find it a bit strange that Mercer
approaches us I'm sure he's confident
that the stasis will hold us but what if
it didn't plus his original appearance
felt a lot better as he was
intentionally trapping Us in here and
then let the monster loose while he was
behind closed doors sort of like a
scientist watching over their experiment
I never really got that same feeling in
the remake furthermore while the scene
with temple is definitely gross part of
me really misses the absurdity of the
original where instead of trapping him
in stasis he ties him to a chair and
then proceeds to stab him in the brain
right in front of us his speech in the
original was also just as great it's
almost like he was some kind of priest
performing a ritual he speaks about the
Divinity of God and how they'll all be
reunited in death Temple was also at Dr
Mercer's Mercy as he wasn't able to do
anything so we just had to watch as this
hopeless man was executed right in front
of us in the remake Temple manages to
wound Mercer which prompts him to skip
the theatrics and just talk to Isaac
about convergence before promptly
shooting temple in the head with what
looks like a nail gun I think in this
case the original did a much better job
at conveying how mentally insane Mercer
truly is the last issue I had though was
his death or I guess death question mark
since it's really unclear if he actually
died I can only imagine the pain of
being squeezed by a tentacle and then
dragged through the ship but once again
I think the original handled this better
his original death sees him willingly
accepting the infector into his arms as
it stabs him through the chest this was
sort of his final act of worship to be
reunited with his so-called God and to
top it all off we run into his newly
formed corpse a second later and have to
put him down it showed the severity and
speed of the infection and once again
continues to convey the fact that Mercer
is a complete radical lunatic with no
sense of morals in the remake it seems
as though he realizes mere moments
before dying that his faith was wrong
and that he had been tricked it's not
terrible and he definitely deserves all
that after the stuff he put Isaac
through but I think him dying as a blind
fanatic is more interesting than him
realizing his mistake right at the end
in all fairness though these are very
minor complaints I'll talk more about my
overall thoughts at the end of the video
but I do want to clarify I had a blast
playing the Remake and these decisions
did not hinder the experience at all
these are just some nitpicks a schmuck
like me would complain about and not
something that brings down the whole
narrative that being said though we
still have the other two people to talk
about who did leave a bit of a sour
taste in my mouth depending on what
parts we're discussing Nicole is both
better and worse than her 2008
counterpart through Nicole the player
gets introduced to side missions and
visual audio logs both of these were not
present in the original and their
appearance here is definitely a welcome
sight especially since most of them
connect to our earlier discussions about
the game wanting to explore unitology a
bit more than before as there's an old
audio log from the original game that
has Captain bias and Dr kind talking
about the marker and unitology but in
the remake There's an actual visual on
screen allowing the player to put a face
to the voices and see what this
so-called marker really is the side
missions were also really well done as
it had a great sense of urgency to them
something that can be hard to pull off
in a survival horror game Isaac is
trying to escape the ishimura as fast as
possible so doing something other than
that goes against the whole story unless
there's a good reason the three main
missions the Remake introduces all
uphold the sense of urgency one of which
is related to increasing your security
clearance which would provide Isaac with
more supplies that he can survive the
ishimura and the other two are related
to Mercer and Nicole Dr Mercer's has
Isaac following a breadcrumb show in
order to understand how and why Mercer
created his Hunter Necromorph I'm
starting to sound like a broken record
here but yes this Mission also paints
Mercer as a lunatic who'll do whatever
he wants if it means furthering
convergence the cool side mission was
also something I liked as it not only
made sense for Isaac to do since it is
his girlfriend after all but also
because it adds more depth to Nicole
Nicole in the original shows up in
person twice in chapters 7 and 11 but
it's only for a few min minutes she does
come up in a hallucination and audio log
here and there but her appearances were
quite brief and the Remake she appears
in another one of these audio logs which
sees her examining a patient this then
leads Isaac down a lengthy side quest in
an attempt to find Nicole obviously he's
not going to find her but throughout the
missions we'll see Nicole attempt to
figure out more about the markers and
the Necromorphs as well as giving us a
chance to learn more about the Clark
family prior to the Remake all we knew
was that Isaac's mom was a unitologist
who used his college funds in order to
pay for a higher rank in the church and
that his dad did some mining operations
before strangely disappearing after some
time in a video call between Isaac and
Nicole it's discovered that Nicole was
trying to help Octavia Clark because she
was dealing with some traumatic issues
which is how she found peace within
unitology Nicole like Isaac though sees
them for what they really are a
fanatical group of scam artists so she
wanted to get Isaac's mom on the right
track without involving the church this
didn't work though is not only did
Octavia kill herself in the name of the
church but she also murdered her husband
AKA Isaac's dad Isaac is extremely
pissed about this and rightfully so
since Nicole told him that she was safe
to return home but clearly that wasn't
true you can clearly tell this hurt
Isaac not only because his parents are
dead but because Nicole told them to go
to hell and ended the call after he blew
up on her at the time she was still on
the ishimura so the two haven't been
able to see each other in person for a
few months and after seeing the state of
the ishimura Isaac is worried that he's
fallen into the Trap that many prey
never happens where your last words to a
loved one are those of hate and anger
while this part was fine the reveal of
her fate felt very forced and needlessly
complicated which brings us to Elizabeth
cross Elizabeth cross is a character
Isaac will meet around chapter 6 right
before fighting the Leviathan in the
original she was imprisoned during this
Mission so I was interested to see how
this would play out and while I did
enjoy her inclusion I was confused as to
not only why she was the only one that
got this treatment but why they kept
using her throughout the story after
defeating the Leviathan Elizabeth cross
disappears and has never heard from
again until right at the end just like
in the original Isaac starts to see
hallucinations of Nicole in chapter 7
and 11. after working together to put
the marker back on the pedestal it's
discovered that the marker had affected
Isaac and made him see who he thought
was Nicole in actuality no one was there
and Kendra confirms this by forcing
Isaac to watch the original video all
the way to the end Isaac didn't want to
watch the whole video though because he
couldn't stomach the idea that she was
truly gone it was a great twist and it
means that you now have to
recontextualize those scenes with Nicole
in it as it confirms that she wasn't
there we talked about this in the Dead
Space Trilogy video quite a bit but I
theorized that all the things Nicole did
like opening the door in chapter 7 and
helping Isaac bring the shuttle back in
chapter 11 were all things he did on his
own but in his mind Nicole did them it's
likely that the door was already opened
during chapter 7 but Isaac didn't notice
and just assumed Nicole helped him it's
definitely spotty and not incredibly
consistent but the hallucinations have
always worked in mysterious ways such as
in Dead Space 2 where Nicole attempts to
stab Isaac but if you succeed it's
discovered that it was just him Nicole
isn't a physical being it's only
something in Isaac's mind so to him he
was getting stabbed by Nicole but to
anyone watching him it just seemed like
Isaac was trying to stab himself I think
this is why the Remake decided to make
the Nicole hallucination an actual
person in order to make sense of these
events because in the remake it's on
that the marker was manipulating two
people cross thought Isaac was Temple
her boyfriend and isaac.cross was Nicole
his girlfriend I was honestly ready to
write quite a few pages about how this
scene is terrible because Kendra if it
followed the original would have just
been holding a gun to the air since the
call could only be seen by Isaac so I'm
glad that the game had cleared this up
and I was quite shocked at the reveal
but I still have to ask why this is my
main issue when it comes to remix I feel
like it's expected that the team changes
up the story in order to justify the
release and while that's completely fair
I feel like motive had tunnel vision
while changing things that needed to be
changed like the ads Canon minigame
among many other things but in the
process of doing so may have overstepped
and changed things that never needed
fixing in the first place this is also a
perfect example of forcing a character
to be a part of the story crossing the
original was practically non-existent
her claim to fame was an appearance in
the occasional audio log but her Emmy
award-winning performance was playing
the role of a corpse on the crew deck
she was completely irrelevant to the
story so adding her makes things more
complicated than they needed to be the
game was going to end up at this Destin
Nation anyway so why bother taking the
scenic route furthermore it seems like
the game was really trying to hint at
this reveal without any sort of subtlety
Nicole is the only one to my knowledge
whose name doesn't appear on the
wriggling calls and instead has its say
unknown contact Plus in chapter 12 not
only is she talking like she's
delusional but the name changes to error
cannot confirm rig ID insinuating that
it may not be Nicole this is also rather
confusing as it technically should say
cross on the rig link as it is her who
is ultimately talking to us and it's not
like her rig link is deactivated as it
was just working fine a few chapters ago
admittedly though I may be looking at
this from a skewed perspective I've
played Dead Space one more time than I
can count so Nicole's death was
something I've known about for years so
I can't get that first playthrough
experience anymore as that happened over
a decade ago so while newer players were
busy trying to find out if Nicole was
alive or not I was busy looking at the
finer details to see how they would pull
off the twist it's like playing a game
for the second or third time on your
first playthrough you're more focused on
the present and not really paying too
much attention but on repeat
playthroughs you start to look at the
smaller details since your mind is no
longer focused on uncovering the main
story if you played the remake for the
first time just recently I would love to
know how this went for you and I'm
curious to see if you were able to guess
the twist before it happened but while
my complaint about her death might be
skewed a bit I don't think cross's
inclusion is as I said it felt like the
team was forced to make a change to the
story even when the twist didn't need a
change in the first place in fact a
perfect example of leaving things how
they should be is our final character Dr
kind Dr kind being a unitologist who saw
the horrors of his religion and realized
that he wanted no part of it was a
perfect setup for his character and the
Remake kept it all intact they also
slightly altered one of his more iconic
video logs the one where he stabs the
captain to make more narrative sense in
the original he stabs the doctor somehow
by accident and is then arrested right
after yet we find him alone in chapter
10 doing just fine in the remake the
captain's death was actually a mistake
this time as Captain Mathias runs right
into the screwdriver killing him on
impact the two guards an attempt to
arrest Dr kind but not before he runs
away which connects to why we find him
alone on the crew deck Dr kind is a
great character in changing him would be
unnecessary so I'm glad the team decided
to keep his role in the store worry the
same
these are the big changes made to dead
space that were worth talking about
there were some smaller things I enjoyed
that I couldn't really figure out where
to put in the script like at the start
of chapter 5 is completely changed as
originally Kendra wanted Isaac to go to
the med Bay to create a poison so they
could kill the organic growth on the
ship which is how he ends up being
trapped by Dr Mercer in the remake Isaac
goes to the Medway because of a
broadcast from Nicole I thought it was a
nice touch and he still ends up arriving
at the same conclusion anyway so it
wasn't a big deal that they changed it
the Remake also used the marker in some
unique ways like changing the text of
the mission log in chapter 10 and also
some of the new game plus text logs just
like before there are some unique text
logs only accessible after beating the
game the original had logs centered
around the crew's background Isaac's mom
and dad as well some reports on the
colony on ages 7 regarding the
Necromorph aging process these were all
pretty much covered in the remake so
they had to add some new ones one was a
conversation between Nicole and
presumably the marker as she was seeing
visions of Isaac's mom but the text
implies that she's not in the room with
her and is speaking to something else
another was a reference to Dead Space
extraction as there was apparently a
group of people who returned from the
colony to to the ishimura after the
outbreak occurred on the planet and the
names of the people are the ones from
extraction the third was octavia's Will
and how she plans to share all her
wealth with the church the fourth was an
advertisement about the sprawl the
setting of Dead Space 2 and the fifth
was indecipherable but I went through
the painstaking process of deciphering
it anyway which talks about the oracles
and possibly the Brethren moons
speaking of new game plus there is also
a second ending which while saying these
words out loud actually makes me realize
that this is not small at all and I
probably should have mentioned this
earlier anyway this is only accessible
on New Game Plus as the game adds these
marker fragments around the map and when
all 12 are placed in Captain matthias's
Quarters the ending is active all you
need to do is play the game like normal
but at the end instead of being jump
scared by Nicole Isaac is talking to
Nicole and plans on building her
something special it's heavily implied
that Isaac has not only succumbed to the
marker and fully believes that Nicole is
real but that the thing he is building
is likely another marker this is rather
interesting as this honestly flows
perfectly into dead space 2. in between
the events of the games we know that
Isaac was found in space and then taken
to the sprawl he was then tested on for
over three years and during that time
the people on the station were using his
mind to create a marker as according to
the lore some people can see things
differently when interacting with the
marker and Isaac is one of them as
always if you want to know more about
that check out the Dead Space video I
made the only problem though is that
Isaac and Dead Space 2 knows Nicole
isn't real so it would be hard to
connect these games together but it's
still a pretty good ending to summarize
my thoughts on the Remake though I think
it's great we could get into a
discussion about whether or not Dead
Space 1 actually needed a remake given
that the original is still readily
available and still holds up to this day
you can discuss that in the comments if
you want to because for now I want to
focus on the point of this video is the
Remake better than the original and
honestly I think so as quick as I made
that out to be it took me a while to
come to that conclusion Deadspace 1 is a
classic and one of the greatest survival
horror games of all time so the Remake
was going to have a tough time living up
to it that being said not only do I
think the Remake is a much better
version of the game even with the issues
we've outlined today the fact that it's
even close in comparison to it speaks
volumes to its level of quality Dead
Space is a fantastic game with such a
unique story and I'm glad that the team
over at motive EA was able to capture
just about all the beauty that made Dead
Space 1 one of the most iconic games of
all time
thanks for watching
if you enjoyed the video please be sure
to like And subscribe as I said at the
top of this video since this is a new
type of content here on the channel let
me know what you think about it in the
comments down below apologies for
bringing this up constantly I promise
this is the last time I'll do it but if
you do like the Dead Space series and
want to see a critique on the game's
story feel free to click the video on
screen now as always thank you to my
returning viewers for coming back to
another video and take care everyone
goodbye